Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Tout le monde a déjà
expérimenté la douleur,
la douleur aiguë,
celle d’une fracture, d’une brûlure,
d’une déchirure, d’une coupure.
Cette douleur, c'est un signal.
Elle nous alerte qu’il y a un
dysfonctionnement, qu’il y a une lésion
et qu'il va falloir trouver la cause,
la réparer, la soigner.
Mais qui, dans cette salle,
a déjà connu la douleur chronique,
celle qui dure plusieurs mois,
au moins trois mois,
et qui va avoir un impact
délétère quotidien
sur votre vie familiale, votre vie
sociale, votre vie professionnelle,
sur vos émotions, sur votre humeur,
sur votre sommeil, etc. ?
Imaginez que vous êtes comme moi,
coincé dans un cercle,
les pieds nus, les jambes découvertes,
et qu’à l’intérieur de ce cercle,
il n’y ait que des orties,
et que vous marchiez dans ces orties.
Qu’il y ait des aiguilles à tricoter
qui se plantent dans votre chair
et qu’il y ait aussi parfois associées
des décharges électriques
dans votre corps, le long de vos bras,
de vos jambes ou de votre thorax.
Cela toute la journée,
la nuit, tous les jours.
Eh bien, contrairement à la douleur aiguë,
que nous connaissons tous,
et qui nous alerte pour protéger
l’intégrité de notre corps,
cette douleur chronique n'est pas utile.
C'est une douleur maladie.
En France, il y a plus
de 10 millions de Français
qui souffrent de cette douleur maladie.
C’est l’une des maladies
les plus fréquentes,
peut-être même la plus fréquente.
Et pourtant, elle est tellement invisible.
Lorsque l’on accompagne des patients
qui souffrent de douleur chronique,
il y a plusieurs étapes.
D’abord, on les accompagne
vers une acceptation
de l’existence de cette douleur,
parce que, sinon,
on s’épuise à lutter contre.
On les accompagne pour déculpabiliser
parce qu’ils n’y sont pour rien
dans cette souffrance.
On les accompagne pour positiver,
pour mieux gérer les émotions négatives
et on les incite à bouger,
à avoir une activité physique.
Pour pas mal de douleurs,
où on a tendance à se replier sur soi,
à ne plus bouger -
ce qu’on appelle la kinésiophobie -
en fait, il faudrait plutôt
continuer à bouger.
La lombalgie est l’un de ces cas-là.
Il y a des traitements médicamenteux,
bien sûr, pour la douleur.
Vous en connaissez :
le paracétamol, les anti-inflammatoires
comme l’Ibuprofène,
les dérivés de la morphine, la morphine
elle-même, le tramadol par exemple,
des antidépresseurs, des anti-épileptiques
et bien d’autres substances.
Il y a des stratégies
non médicamenteuses : la psychothérapie,
la kinésithérapie,
de la neuro-stimulation,
parfois des approches sociales
car la douleur chronique parfois aboutit
à des complications professionnelles,
voire à des pertes d’emploi.
Eh bien, malgré toutes ces stratégies,
une grande majorité des patients
ne sont pas bien,
voire pas du tout, soulagés.
Et l'innovation thérapeutique est en berne
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années
concernant la prise en charge
de la douleur chronique.
Aujourd’hui, après cette
un peu longue introduction,
je souhaitais vous parler de l’intérêt
des médicaments à base de cannabis
pour ces patients, notamment, dont
la qualité de vie est fortement altérée.
Ces patients qui souffrent
de douleurs chroniques, réfractaires.
Ce cannabis,
on sait depuis longtemps qu’il a pu être
utilisé dans une finalité thérapeutique.
Il y a des écrits qui existent,
des écrits chinois, indiens, égyptiens
qui ont plus de 2 000 ans
et qui rapportent un usage à la fois dans
la douleur et dans d’autres indications.
Pour la douleur, on le retrouve déjà
pour arracher des dents,
pour les règles douloureuses, pour les
accouchements, pour des opérations.
C’était très empirique, je vous l’accorde,
mais c’était déjà utilisé.
A la fin du 19e, au début du 20ᵉ siècle,
les pharmaciens en France préparaient
des médicaments à partir de ça.
C’était là aussi très empirique,
parfois assez risqué.
Puis, avec les découvertes de la médecine,
on a enfin compris comment fonctionnaient
les molécules à l’intérieur du cannabis,
certaines de ces molécules,
et on a vu apparaître de plus en plus
de pays qui ont légalisé l’accès
à ces produits dérivés du cannabis
ou au cannabis lui-même.
Certains pays ont autorisé l’auto-culture
de cannabis par les patients eux-mêmes,
à condition que ça soit
à visée thérapeutique.
D’autres sont allés plus loin,
jusqu’à autoriser des médicaments,
des produits de qualité pharmaceutique,
autorisés par des agences sanitaires
comme l’Agence du médicament en France.
Autour de nous, l’Angleterre,
l’Allemagne, le Luxembourg,
les Pays-Bas, le Portugal,
l’Italie, la Suisse,
ont déjà donné accès à ces produits.
Le Canada, premier pays à avoir légalisé
le cannabis thérapeutique en 2001
a une approche un peu particulière.
Ils sont allés beaucoup
plus loin que nous encore,
puisque les chercheurs
et les restaurateurs canadiens
(Rires)
se sont intéressés à la souffrance animale
et ont testé
dans des publications scientifiques
l’intérêt de la fumée du cannabis -
donc c’est du homard fumé -
(Rires)
pour vérifier
qu’ils souffraient un peu moins -
un peu moins parce
qu’ils finissaient toujours ébouillantés.
(Rires)
Nul doute qu’à l’heure
des réseaux sociaux,
nous allons avoir des revendications de la
part de nos homards bretons, évidemment.
(Rires)
Mais plus sérieusement,
cette plante au sein
de son inflorescence, de sa fleur,
et non pas au niveau de sa feuille
que l’on voit souvent représentée,
au sein de ses inflorescences,
contient des substances actives.
Il existe des petites
structures glandulaires,
des petites glandes
qui contiennent un liquide,
et au sein de ce liquide,
des centaines de substances.
A partir de ces substances,
on va pouvoir faire des produits à visée
thérapeutique issus du cannabis.
Deux substances principales,
les plus connues,
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler,
les mieux caractérisées parmi d’autres
dont je n’aurais pas le temps de parler :
le THC, tétrahydrocannabinol,
c’est la substance qu’on peut
utiliser en thérapeutique,
mais qu’on connaît bien dans un usage
qualifié de récréatif, festif, social,
c’est-à-dire l’usage désinhibiteur,
euphorisant, planant, etc.
Et puis le CBD, le cannabidiol,
dont on parle beaucoup dans les médias,
et puis aussi en ville avec
des boutiques qui fleurissent beaucoup
avec cette substance, le cannabidiol,
qui lui aussi est une substance contenue
dans certaines variétés de cannabis
qui a aussi des effets psychoactifs,
mais beaucoup moins prononcés que le THC,
et qui peut avoir des effets
complémentaires sur un plan thérapeutique.
Ces deux substances, elles vont
aller agir sur des récepteurs,
des récepteurs qui se trouvent
partout dans notre corps,
des dizaines de récepteurs différents.
Pas uniquement au niveau du cerveau,
on en trouve au niveau des os, du cœur,
du foie, de la peau,
des muscles, par exemple.
Et donc, en agissant sur ces récepteurs,
on espère pouvoir corriger
un dysfonctionnement
dans un sens ou dans un autre,
en cherchant à bloquer
ou en cherchant à activer.
Et on espère pouvoir
rétablir l’homéostasie,
c’est-à-dire l’équilibre
de fonctionnement du corps humain.
Le THC et le CBD sont connus, par exemple,
pour ce qui nous concerne aujourd’hui,
pour interférer sur la transmission
des messages douloureux
et leur arrivée au niveau du cerveau.
Ils sont aussi connus pour pouvoir
interférer sur la gestion des émotions.
En cela, ces deux substances
peuvent être intéressantes
dans un but thérapeutique chez des
patients avec des douleurs chroniques.
En France, on prend notre temps.
On s'inspire de ce qui a été fait autour
de nous et on a lancé une expérimentation,
une expérimentation,
pas un essai clinique.
Ce n’est pas de la recherche, c’est une
expérimentation de politique publique
au sens où la Constitution l'entend.
On va pouvoir expérimenter un dispositif
qui, en dehors, n’est pas légal,
mais à l’intérieur, le devient,
et qui va permettre de guider la décision
publique, la décision politique.
Cette expérimentation, elle a -
La réflexion a débuté en 2018
et ça a abouti à la première prescription
de ces médicaments à base de cannabis
le 26 mars 2021, ici à Clermont-Ferrand.
Et depuis, 2100 patients ont été traités
en France métropolitaine et outremer,
c’est-à-dire en 18 mois.
C’est peu, mais c’est déjà pas mal,
compte tenu du dispositif
qui a été mis en place.
Les indications ont été
validées scientifiquement
à partir des données de la littérature.
Elles ont été validées
par l’Agence du médicament
** et par le ministère de la Santé
qui s’est emparé de la question.
Cinq grandes indications.
La douleur neuropathique,
celle que vous avez vécue tout à l’heure
dans le cercle vert, plein d’orties.
La spasticité douloureuse,
des raideurs, des contractions
musculaires anormales,
comme dans la sclérose en plaques
ou chez les patients qui ont fait
des accidents vasculaires cérébraux,
Dans certains symptômes
rebelles en oncologie,
des complications du cancer
ou des traitements du cancer,
ça peut être la douleur,
des pertes d’appétit,
ça peut être des nausées,
vomissements, difficiles à contrôler.
Dans des situations palliatives diverses
qui concernent l’oncologie,
mais pas uniquement.
Et enfin, une cinquième indication, ce
sont les épilepsies pharmaco-résistantes,
c’est-à-dire celles qui résistent
à trois, quatre traitements différents,
aussi bien chez l’enfant
que chez l’adulte.
Dans l’épilepsie, on utilise plus
particulièrement des médicaments
qui contiennent du CBD et
non ceux qui contiennent du THC.
Il y a toute une famille
de médicaments à disposition.
Ce n’est pas un médicament, le cannabis
médical ou ceux à base de cannabis,
c’est une famille
de compositions différentes
qui ont des taux différents
en THC ou en CBD.
Soit c'est très THC, soit c'est très CBD,
soit c'est un équilibre entre les deux.
Nous, on fait nos mélanges.
Ce sont des huiles, des extractions
de la fleur sous forme d’huile,
qu’ils vont prendre par voie orale,
ou bien des fleurs, des fleurs séchées
de cannabis qui vont être broyées,
positionnées à l’intérieur
d’un dispositif dit de vaporisation,
qui va chauffer la fleur à 190 °C environ,
juste pour dégager une vapeur
qui contiendra le THC et/ou le CBD,
qui sera inhalée, mais en revanche
sans les risques liés à la combustion -
les risques de cancer,
les risques cardio-vasculaires -
qu’on retrouve dans un joint.
Il n’y a pas de joint thérapeutique ;
en tout cas, pas en médecine.
Vous vous souvenez
de votre immersion tout à l’heure
dans la peau d’un malade souffrant
de douleurs neuropathiques -
puisque c’est ça que je vous ai décrit -
une douleur neuropathique.
Les orties, des aiguilles, des brûlures
parfois, des décharges électriques.
Six à 7% des Français souffrent
de ces douleurs neuropathiques.
Deux tiers d’entre eux ne sont pas
soulagés par les traitements
qui sont en première intention
antidépresseurs, anti-épileptiques
et parfois le tramadol.
C’est dans cette douleur neuropathique
que nous disposons le plus
de preuves scientifiques
pour proposer des traitements,
des médicaments à base de cannabis.
Dans l’expérimentation que j’ai citée,
2100 patients traités,
700 étaient traités pour une douleur
neuropathique réfractaire.
Je vous donne
quelques résultats d’efficacité.
Deux tiers d’entre eux ont rapporté
une amélioration de leur qualité de vie.
Quatre sur dix ont rapporté une
diminution significative de leur anxiété.
La douleur, ce n’est pas
que son intensité,
c’est le sommeil, c’est l’anxiété,
c’est le moral et tout le reste.
Quand on étudie des patients qui souffrent
de douleurs, on s’intéresse à tout ça.
Une partie d’entre eux ont rapporté
une diminution importante
des douleurs, des accès douloureux,
des pics de douleur.
Deux fois moins de patients décrivent
leur douleur comme insupportable.
Ce sont quelques résultats parmi d'autres.
C’est un traitement qui traite
le patient dans sa globalité.
C’est un traitement holistique.
Le mot est très à la mode,
mais c’est vraiment ça.
On ne se focalise pas sur la douleur, mais
sur la diversité des symptômes du patient.
Ces traitements ne sont pas efficaces
parce qu'ils sont d'origine naturelle.
Il existe beaucoup de drogues
d’origine naturelle utilisées en médecine,
d'origine végétale, animale, minérale.
Ce n’est pas pour ça qu’elles sont
efficaces ou non dangereuses.
C’est juste qu’on a des récepteurs
qui peuvent recevoir ces substances
contenues dans la nature
et on peut s’en servir
pour moduler ces récepteurs.
Mais ce n’est
ni plus dangereux ni plus efficace
qu’une drogue qui serait de synthèse.
Une précision tout de même :
l’immense majorité des patients
inclus dans cette expérimentation
n’avaient jamais consommé
de cannabis au préalable.
Ce n’est pas un cheval de Troie
pour essayer de légaliser
l’accès au cannabis non médical.
C’est une expérimentation
et ce sera, je l’espère, un jour,
des traitements en soins courants
pour traiter des patients qui souffrent,
qu'ils soient ou non consommateurs
de cannabis au préalable.
Pour terminer, comme pour
tous les traitements, bien sûr,
les bénéfices ne vont jamais
sans effets indésirables.
Il faut que ces bénéfices soient
supérieurs aux effets indésirables.
Les médicaments à base de cannabis ont
leurs effets indésirables : neurologiques,
surtout pour ceux qui contiennent du THC :
sédation, somnolence, vertiges ;
des effets indésirables digestifs,
qui ne leur sont pas très spécifiques,
des effets indésirables psychiatriques -
plutôt de l’anxiété,
il est rare de voir des hallucinations,
de la paranoïa, ça peut arriver -
mais il y a une contre-indication
qui est les troubles psychotiques
ou la schizophrénie -
on ne traite pas ces patients
avec ces médicaments pour l’instant.
Il y a des complications
cardio-vasculaires.
Le THC peut augmenter le rythme cardiaque
et entraîner des palpitations.
Ce sont les effets indésirables.
On n’a pas observé de cas de dépendance,
d’abus, de mésusage, pour l’instant,
dans ces 18 mois de traitement.
Soulager la souffrance
sans nuire aux patients,
c’est la raison d'être de la médecine.
Espérons que les médicaments
à base de cannabis
viennent un jour en France élargir
l’éventail des thérapeutiques
pour traiter les patients souffrant
de douleurs neuropathiques réfractaires.
(Applaudissements)